TEACHERS.
IT IS STILL NOT CLEAR WHEN THE
STUDENTS WILL RETURN.
>> John: STEVE HARRIGAN IN
FORT LAUDERDALE, FLORIDA.
THANKS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE GUN-CONTROL
PORTION WITH HER THIS TIME
THINGS MIGHT BE ACTUALLY BE
DIFFERENT.
SENIOR POLITICAL BRIT HUME IS
WITH US.
WE'VE HAD TURNING POINTS IN THE
PAST.
WE HAD THE SANDY HOOK ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL SHOOTING IN CONNECTICUT.
THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING IN
ORLANDO, THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING
PAIN IN THE WAKE OF ALL OF
THOSE, THERE WERE CALLS FOR MORE
GUN CONTROL OR AT LEAST IN THE
WAKE OF LAS VEGAS, A BAN ON
THOSE SO-CALLED BONE STOCK.
YOU HAD OVER 100 PIECES OF
GUN-CONTROL LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION HAVE GONE NOWHERE.
WILL ANYTHING CHANGE THIS TIME
AROUND?
>> IT FEELS AS IF SOMETHING
MIGHT.
PARTLY IT'S BECAUSE THE
ACCUSATION OF THESE INCIDENTS IN
THE PUBLIC'S REACTION TO THEM.
PARTLY I THINK IT'S THAT THESE
YOUNG STUDENTS WHO HAVE COME
FORWARD.
YOU SAW THEM YESTERDAY ON THE
SUNDAY SHOWS THEY ARE PLANNING A
MARCH NEXT MONTH, THEY'VE BEEN
QUITE EFFECTIVE.
THERE IS AS TENSE COUPLED WITH
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
NOW TALKING ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING TO STRENGTHEN THE
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM AND MAKE
IT WORK A LITTLE BETTER.
WE MIGHT GET SOMETHING THIS TIME
AROUND.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO ADD THAT IN
THIS CASE, WE HAVE A REAL
CULPRIT IN THE SENSE OF THE FBI
AND THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES IN
FLORIDA DOING SUCH A POOR JOB OF
RESPONDING TO THE CLEAR WARNINGS
THEY HAD THAT THIS YOUNG MAN,
THIS VERY YOUNG MAN WHO WAS
IDENTIFIED TO THEM BY NAME WAS A
DANGER.
THE FBI DROPPED THE BALL AND SO
DID LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
IT'S POSSIBLE SOMETHING COULD BE
DONE TO ENCOURAGE A BETTER
RESPONSE BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THAT
WILL TAKE SOME OF THE FOCUS OFF
MORE GUN CONTROL.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT HAS
TOLD PEOPLE AT MAR-A-LAGO OVER
THE WEEKEND THAT HE WOULD COME
OUT IN FAVOR OF STRENGTHENING
BACKGROUND CHECKS, THE BILL
BEING FLOATED BY SENATORS JOHN
CORNYN AND CHRIS MURPHY.
ALL OF THIS WOULD DO WOULD
IMPROVE THE APPLICATION OF
CURRENT LAW.
WITH THAT REALLY ANYTHING?
>> WELL, IT MIGHT.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT.
YOU ARE RIGHT IT'S ALL ABOUT
CURRENT LAW AND IT'S ABOUT THE
FAILURE OF CURRENT LAW TO DO THE
JOB, JUST AS IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WE SAW THE FAILURE OF
AUTHORITIES TO DO THEIR JOB.
WHAT MIGHT COME OUT OF THIS
WOULD BE A RESOLVE IN THAT AREA.
WHETHER ANYTHING -- FIRST OF
ALL, YOU HAVE THIS PROBLEM, WE
ALWAYS HAVE THIS ONE WE HAVE
THESE EPISODES WHERE SOME WEAPON
IS USED OR SOME CIRCUMSTANCES
ENCOUNTERED AND IT TURNS OUT
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED TO ADDRESS
IT WOULDN'T HAVE ADDRESSED THE
CASE IN PARTICULAR.
THIS WAS NOT A BAND WEAPON, THIS
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPON WAS NOT.
EFFORTS TO BAN THOSE IN THE PAST
HAVE GONE NOWHERE.
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT LEGISLATING
DON'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY WORK OR WHATEVER.
WE'LL SEE IF THIS IS DIFFERENT
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT TO BE
SKEPTICAL.
>> John: YOU MENTIONED THE FBI
DROPPING THE BALL ON A TIP THEY
GOT IN JANUARY THAT THE MAYOR
MAY NOT HAVE PREVENTED THIS BUT
AT LEAST THEY WOULD'VE KNOWN
ABOUT IT.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED ABOUT THAT
OVER THE WEEKEND, SAYING
"VERY SAD THAT THE FBI MISSED
ALL OF THE MANY SIGNALS SENT OUT
BY THE FLORIDA SCHOOL SHOOTER.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE."
GOES ON TO SAY:
"THEY ARE SPENDING TOO MUCH TIME
TRYING TO PROVE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
GET BACK TO THE BASICS AND MAKE
US ALL PROUD!"
THE PRESIDENT WAS WIDELY
CRITICIZED FOR THAT TWEET.
DID HE HELP HIMSELF?
>> I'M SURE IT FIRED UP HIS
SUPPORTERS.
A LOT OF THEM SEEM TO LIKE THAT.
BUT THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY WITH HIM AND WILL BE
WITH HIM.
IT DOES NOTHING TO EXPAND HIS
SUPPORT, AND HIS COMMENTS ABOUT
THE FBI'S PERFORMANCE ON THIS
CASE ARE PERFECTLY VALID.
BUT THE FBI IS A GREAT BIG
INSTITUTION WITH THOUSANDS OF
AGENTS DISPERSED ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WHETHER A FAILURE IN THE MIAMI
FIELD OFFICE OR WHATEVER OFFICE
WAS RESPONSIBLE HAD ANYTHING
WHATEVER TO DO WITH THE EXTENT
OF THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION, I
THINK THAT'S DOUBTFUL.
SO I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
PROBABLY NOT STANDING ON VERY
SOLID FACTUAL GROUND THERE IN